[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten abend zu die
richtigen fragen an einem so muss man es
sagen dramatischen wochenende die
kriegsangst ist da sie kriegsangst in
europa darüber möchte ich diskutieren
mit meinen gästen mit dem ukrainischen
botschafter andere melnik mit dem
außenpolitischen sprecher der grünen
jürgen trittin mit alexander von graf
lambsdorff stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender und mit dem
außenpolitischen sprecher der union
jürgen hat ja und wie dramatisch das
ganze ist das zeigt uns ein video das
zeigt uns eine pressekonferenz mit jacks
sullivan dem nationalen
sicherheitsberater der usa
in russland die ukraine angreift wird
das wohl mit flächenbombardements und
raketenangriffen beginnen dabei würden
zivilisten sterben egal welche
nationalität sie habe
eine bodenoffensive würde bedeuten dass
eine gewaltige menge an truppen
einrücken würde ohne weitere vorwarnung
wenig wenn man das hört dramatische
worte aus den usa sie haben familie
freunde in kiew natürlich als
botschafter wie nah sind wir vor dem
krieg
also wir haben schon ein gefühl dass ein
krieg er immer unausweichlicher werte es
herrsche ein gefühl der angst
selbstverständlich weil wir diese gefahr
vor augen seit wochen seit monaten sehen
auf der anderen seite was wir auch sehen
und spüren es die entschlossenheit der
menschen
ihre heimat zu verteidigen und zwar mit
allen mitteln die uns zur verfügung
stehen und da ist auch nach wie vor
unsere bitte an die deutsche politik
umzudenken und es gibt noch die letzte
chance diesen krieg zu verhindern
diplomatische aber
wir müssen gleichzeitig auch die
richtigen schritte unternehmen wenn ich
sage wir das heißt die deutschen freunde
die partner die wir haben wir zählen auf
sie wir zählen auf diese einsicht dass
man natürlich diplomatisch weiterhin
agieren muss aber das reicht leider
nicht aus herr trittin wie nahe stehen
wir vor einem krieg mitten in europa
muss man sagen zwei flugstunden hier von
berlin entfernt das ist eine sehr offene
frage die fakten die
auf dem grund erkennbar sind das den
aufmärschen angeht was die nachgezogene
versorgungs kräfte der russen angeht das
sind jetzt nicht mehr nur kampfgruppen
und ähnliche dinge die sagen sie seien
in der lage diese invasion tatsächlich
auszuführen die offene frage ist ob sie
sich dazu entschieden haben dann gibt es
zwischen den diensten wenn ich das sehe
sehr unterschiedliche interpretationen
ich glaube dass in dieser situation erst
richtig gewesen ist dass beiden mit
putin gesprochen hat dass es richtig ist
dass man kaum mit putin spricht und das
ist wichtig ist dass der deutsche
bundeskanzler am montag nach kiel fährt
und am dienstag dann mit putin spricht
denn es muss ihm klar gemacht werden
dass das worauf putin heute setzen
könnte nämlich eine militärische
eskalation
alles riskiert was er in beziehung mit
europa hat wirtschaftlich und politisch
hamster auf das hören wir häufig man
muss härter mit putin sprechen jetzt
sagen die amerikaner am mittwoch beginnt
möglicherweise der krieg das können sie
nicht belegen wir wissen nicht was putin
entscheiden würden wir wissen nicht ob
es ein befehl gegeben hat was jack
sullivan da verkündet hat ist ein
denkbares szenario
es ist kein belegte szenario und
deswegen müssen wir und das ist der
appell auch des bundespräsidenten heute
in seiner rede müssen wir alles dafür
tun dafür zu sorgen dass es nicht dazu
kommt denn wir dürfen als ich vergessen
botschafter namik hat das gerade gesagt
in der ukraine gibt es eine große
entschlossenheit das land zu verteidigen
das eigene land die heimat zu
verteidigen mit allen zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln das heißt das wird
nicht eine leichte operation für den
fall dass ich die russen dazu
entschließen sollten herr trittin hat
gerade gesagt sollten die russen
wirklich da einmarschieren würde alles
zusammenbrechen was es an beziehungen
gibt zwischen russland und dem westen so
dass sie im grunde nur noch die chance
haben sich in china anzulegen das heißt
sie hätten eine widerständige ukraine
sie versuchen wollen zu kontrollieren
sie hätten wir die beziehungen zum
westen völlig kaputt und während total
abhängig von china das ist nicht im
russischen nationalen im ausland bislang
nicht aufgehalten zu haben er hat eben
immer weitere truppen an der grenze
zusammen zu ziehen und jetzt gibt es
eben diese aussagen aus den usa warum
macht man das denn dort dann so konkret
wenn via lambsdorff und andere sagen man
ist so genau auch wieder nicht weil es
eine konkrete gefahr ist und zunächst
mal mit alexander lambsdorff recht geben
wenn die gegenwärtige diskussion etwas
zeigt dass dann der dass der plan von
putin durch seine
überfall auf die krim und den einfluss
in der ost ukraine vor acht jahren das
auf diese weise ein stück weit die
ukraine
rausholt aus dieser europafreundlichkeit
dass das nicht eingetreten ist sondern
dass im gegenteil dieser russische druck
über die vielen jahre das hat den
menschen geholfen sie haben sich in
europa ausgedrückt und am ende werden ja
also sie werden nicht alleingelassen zu
werden wirtschaftlich und politisch
massiv unterstützt von europa nicht
zuletzt auch von deutschland die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung der ukraine
ist eine kategorie ahl bessere seit wir
das assoziationsabkommen mit der in
jahre haben und diese ganzen maßnahmen
da wird extrem viel getan ich glaube das
weiß die ukrainische bevölkerung auch
aber ich glaube der meinte mond in
diesem land ist eben auch ganz klar dass
man sich von russland nicht pressen
lassen will und das einzige mittel was
putin möglicherweise sieht um seine
politik doch noch zum erfolg zu führen
ist die militärische karte wenn er
vernünftig ist rené rational handelt
wird er diese sache bleiben lassen aber
sind wir sicher dass er tatsächlich in
einer lage ist in der rational handelt
kann es nicht sein dass etwas
irrationales passiert was hinterher
nicht rückholbar ist das ist die große
sorge die ich habe wenig was kann olaf
scholz der deutsche bundeskanzler jetzt
tun er reist morgen nach kiew dann
fliegt er zurück auch um diplomatische
schwierigkeiten zu vermeiden um dann
wieder nach russland zu reisen in
früheren zeiten wäre man natürlich von
kiew direkt weiter nach moskau geflogen
was kann man jetzt tun
wir glauben dass das womöglich auch die
letzte chance sein wird für die
weltgemeinschaft und für herrn schultz
der ja nicht nur als bundeskanzler
sondern vor allem auch als vorsitzender
der g7 staaten nach gehe von der nach
moskau fliegt und das einzige was herr
scholz jetzt in seinem gepäck mitnehmen
sollte wäre ein klares ultimatum
sofort aufzuhören mit fristen was
geschieht und zwar tagtäglich ja wenn
die gruppe nicht abgezogen werden am
mittwoch dann werden folgende sanktionen
sofort eingeführt dass man präventiv
agiert und nicht mehr abwarten so die
zeit wurde vergeudet die wertvolle zeit
zwei monate jetzt ist die zeit gekommen
um endlich zu handeln trittin sanktionen
sofort um putin unter druck zu setzen
ich glaube dass der weg den wir und zwar
die deutsche bundesregierung sei zum
amtes mit mittlerweile zwei besuchen der
bundesaußenminister in kiew einem besuch
in moskau mit dem jetzt vorgesehenen
diplomatie durch den bundeskanzler mit
dem in der letzten woche stattgefunden
habenden verhandlungen im normandie
format zwischen siemann geführt haben
genauso wie die besucher so ist das so
ist das immer dass bei diplomatie sie
nicht morgens ein ergebnis haben wenn
sie sich abends treffe aber man wünscht
sich ja dann schon dass zumindest die
sache ist nicht weiter eskaliert wie ich
den leuten nur darauf hinweisen hatte es
keine passivität gegeben und es gibt in
der nächsten woche donnerstag erneut ein
treffen in diesem format das heißt
deutschland kümmert sich nicht nur darum
das assoziationsabkommen mit der ukraine
mit leben zu füllen dort massiv zu
investieren
ich habe erst in der letzten woche
hennig war dabei die stellvertretende
ministerpräsidentin der ukraine
getroffen wo wir über fragen der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit
gearbeitet haben sondern eben auch mit
klaren botschaften richtung russland es
ist nicht so dass man das nur auf
diplomatie und worte beschränkt die
antwort die europa hierzu gegeben hat
war sehr eindeutig und sie war auch
eindeutig im konzert der nato das heißt
zwischen europa und den usa abgestimmt
wir werden eine weitere man muss das
wort weiter immer unterstreichen
russland verletzt täglich die
territoriale integrität der ukraine in
donezk
im don was in dieser situation wie sind
in einer solchen situation wir werden
das weiter nicht akzeptieren und auf
dieser basis sprechen wir und wenn es
auf dieser basis keine einigung gibt
wenn es kalt nun gibt es eine antwort
darauf wie viel angst haben sie
persönlich vor einem krieg sie waren
teil einer bundesregierung die damals
den kosovo krieg miterlebt hat wo
schwere entscheidungen für die grünen
getroffen werden mussten was macht das
mit ihnen persönlich ich glaube dass wir
aus dieser situation eines gelernt haben
dass man wirklich alles tun muss um eine
solche militärische eskalation zu
vermeiden das ist glaube ich auch der
erfahrungshintergrund den olaf scholz in
diese gespräche mit einbringt
dennoch ich kann niemandem ernsthaft
sagen das bin ich glaube ich hier im
breiten konsens dass das nicht
stattfinden würde ich würde auch sagen
mit herrn hart es gibt eine überragende
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es nicht im
interesse russlands ist militärisch zu
eskalieren aber wenn ich mir anschaue
mit welcher intensität beispielsweise
putin locker schenker in belarus
gestützt hat das modell des
machtverlustes vor augen das war
sichtbar das war sein eigenes menetekel
was an dieser stelle gewesen war da weiß
ich nicht was die rationalität ist der
lernenden die vornehmlich die
rationalität der erhaltung der
herrschaft auch um einen sehr hohen
preis möglicherweise auch mit dem preis
eines blutigen krieges in der ukraine
und es findet in belarus ja dieses
referendum statt dieses gefakte von
lukaschenko und eine maßnahme das haben
wir letzte woche und auch nochmal mit
frau der moskauer diskutiert in vilnius
eine maßnahme ist den artikel aus der
verfassung der von belarus zu streichen
dass belarus ein atomwaffenfreies land
ist das heißt im klartext wenn diese
verfassung so angenommen wird was ja
angesichts der feldstudie da stattfindet
klar ist kann lukaschenko jederzeit
putin einladen atomwaffen an der
polnischen grenze zu stationieren also
ich bin schon beunruhigt dass da
möglicherweise auch noch einen bahn
größerer plan dahin waren sie alle
nehmen sie jetzt mal alle zusammen
außerdem klinischen botschafter in den
vergangenen zehn 15 jahren auch die
kanzlerin zu naiv was wladimir putin
angeht man hat immer gehofft ja mensch
wenn man mit ihm spricht wenn man
versucht das verhältnis zu verbessern
dann wird schon jetzt nichts großes
weiteres passieren okay die krim das ist
jetzt so die ost ukraine
aber jetzt stehen wir möglicherweise vor
einer diesen umfassenden invasion die
dazu führen kann dass hunderttausende
menschen sterben millionen flüchtlinge
es geben könnte mit in europa wir haben
potenzial überschätzt als führer
russlands was die entwicklung des
eigenen landes angeht wir haben gedacht
wenn putin mit unserer unterstützung mit
dem riesigen erlösen aus den gas- und
ölverkäufen wenn er damit russland zu
einer modernen nation des 21
jahrhunderts macht ein stück weit näher
die eu bringt den handels und
wirtschaftsfragen dann werden wir auf
diese weise auch den frieden sichern wir
haben aber leider festgestellt dass
putin ein ziemlich erfolgloser in der
innenpolitik in der wirtschaftspolitik
ziemlich hervor großer präsident ist in
russland die infrastruktur die
diversifizierung der industrie was ist
die naivität der und ich das war die
naivität dass wir das wir putin
wahrscheinlich in seiner kraft russland
nach vorne zu bringen total überschätzt
haben so dass wir jetzt erleben dass er
nur die militärische karte noch spielen
krake war eine ausnahme es gibt eine
ausnahme und die ist natürlich
bemerkenswert es ist nicht gelungen die
russische wirtschaft zu modernisieren
und zu diversifizieren ist aber sehr
wohl gelungen das russische militär zu
modernisieren wenn es eine reform gibt
dann ist es die große russische militär
fern der letzten zehn jahre mit train
suv in syrien mit operationen mit
vermindertem risiko auf der krim und im
donbass wo man proxies nutzt also
vorgeschobene andere aber im grunde
wirklich dahinter steckt und wir sehen
nicht was ich gelernt habe ich es gerade
im hintergrund gelaufen ist wie gerhard
schröder dort in den vergangenen jahren
eine immer größere rolle gespielt hat
der platine putin unterstützt hat er
weiter aufgerückt ist jetzt bei rosneft
bei gazprom diese entscheidende rolle
spielt herr trittin sie kennen gerd
schröder als kanzler was macht das mit
ihnen
ich habe zu diesem engagement
gesagt das ist nicht im deutschen
interesse
jedenfalls wenn ich cher
verwaltungsratsvorsitzender einer dem
russischen staat gehören und mehrheit
nicht gehören und ölgesellschaft bin
dann will ich dem russischen staat
verpflichtet nicht der deutschen der
deutschen gesellschaften deswegen hätte
ich an bundeskanzler des nie geraten
einen solchen schritt zu tun haben sie
mir angerufen und gesagt mensch gehört
love gelegentlich spricht man auch so
was sagt aber ich will will nur auf
einen anderen punkt nach hause weil ich
finde da muss man auch ein stück selbst
kritisch alle zurück wir waren sehr früh
auf der auffassung dass der ansatz
handel schafft wandel mit putin nicht
funktioniert wir sind lange belächelt
worden dass wenn wir nach russland
fahren regelmäßig uns mit memorial und
anderen
bürgerrechtsorganisationen getroffen
haben dass wir die fragen was ist
eigentlich im tschetschenien krieg das
war der beginn von putins herrschaft
dass wir das immer thematisiert haben
und wir stellen heute fest dass die
entwicklung in russland lernprozesse
auch ausgelöst hat bei allen parteien
fühlen uns gar nicht ausnehmen an dieser
stelle wir haben auch diese dimension
nicht vorhergesehen aber zu einer
gravierenden veränderung wenn sie den
rede hören die der bundespräsident heute
gehalten hat die hätte der
bundespräsident vor zehn jahren als er
bundesaußenminister gewesen ist nicht
der ruhr bundespräsident der einst
kanzleramtsminister von gerhard schröder
war und darauf zurückzukommen macht sie
das wenn sie das sehen wieder gerhard
schröder wladimir putin die hand schütte
der mann der jetzt ihre verwandten in
kiew bedroht der am ende dort menschen
töten kann da sind wir natürlich wütend
aber bevor ich diese frage behandelt
dann darf möchte ich das was herr graf
lambsdorff ansprache ganz kurz erwähnen
die einzige der vorrunde erfolgreich war
war die frau die reform der russischen
armee und das was wir heute in der welt
am sonntag gelesen haben da gibt es eine
recherche die belegt dass deutschland
wie möglich dabei auch stark mitgeholfen
hat indem man alleine im jahre 2020 so
genannte dual use kurze das heißt waren
die auch für das militär genutzt werden
können und vielleicht wurden sie genutzt
in der höhe von fast 400 millionen euro
gebilligt hatte und russland stand an
der vierten stelle für die
bundesrepublik das heißt das hat uns
also die gesamte gesellschaft heute früh
umgehauen dass man uns denn und trainern
die waffen verweigert also für die
selbstverteidigung und gleichzeitig der
eindruck entsteht dass dass deutschland
dabei die russen gerade bei diesen
kriegsvorbereitungen wie möglich
unterstützt hat das unternehmen das das
heißt doppelter moral und deutschland
spiel so oft diese moralapostel dass es
etwas was wir nicht verstehen können und
herr schröder ist nur ein weiterer beleg
dass diese verlogenheit der politik ein
ausmaß erreicht hatte dass man einfach
sprachlos ist also wir haben nach der
dem überfall russlands auf die krim und
die ein entsprechender einrichtungen aus
der ukraine
militär projekte die wir mit russland
gemeinsam hatten also angefangen von
übungen bis hin zum gefäßzentrum und es
waren noch 3 bis zwei hubschrauberträger
die die franzosen wiederum liefern
wollten das ist gestoppt worden sie
kennen die diskussion ich glaube die
hubschrauberträger sind dann hinterher
in ägypten gelandet also es hat eine ein
abbruch der militär zusammenarbeit mit
russland als vorher bleibt ja dabei also
es entsteht der eindruck wir helfen am
ende putin und den ukrainern sagen wir
sorry können ihnen leider nicht helfen
waffen wollen wir nicht liefern das
macht putin wie ist das möglich also
wirtschaftlich und politisch also
politisch stehen wir glaubt das sage ich
rede genau von diesem bericht den herrn
mendig angesprochen hat wirtschaftlich
tun wir mehr für die ukraine gemessen
auch an der größe des landes als für
russland russland profitiert natürlich
von den verkäufen von gas öl ist klar
also wir kaufen russisches gas und
finanzieren damit ein stück weit den
russischen staatshaushalt das ist das
ergebnis der tatsache dass wir auf gas
angewiesen sind und russland eben große
mengen günstigen gases zur verfügung hat
aber dass wir in der art und weise dass
wir dieses land entwickeln und stützen
so mit russland zusammenarbeiten wie mit
der ukraine dreht sich um den vergleich
sondern um die frage das ist ja
angesprochen worden hält nämlich was
sozusagen am ende dann eine direkte
unterstützung auch der russischen armee
bedeutet hat also das werden wir uns
natürlich mehr angucken auch auf der
grundlage dieses berichtes der user sind
halt immer dinge lkw frage stelle
vermutlich und solche dinge die man so
oder so ausrüsten kann ich glaube dass
beide hughes auch genauso scharf
hingeguckt wird wie bei klassischen
rüstungsexporten deswegen bin ich nicht
ganz sicher ob sich das so erwartet aber
ich bin natürlich der meinung dass dinge
die militärisch in russland genutzt
werden nicht aus deutschen fabriken
richtung ostring und produktionsanlagen
also für waffen herstellung es ging bei
diesem bericht um freitag für den
flugzeugbau und es gibt auch
chemische
substanzen die uns immer wieder und ich
kann mich erinnern in den letzten jahren
haben wir immer wieder angefragt unsere
wirtschaft dass bestimmte de rossi kurz
auch uns
quasi an die ukraine exportiert werden
dürfen und da gab es absagen auch wenn
es um pulver gegen das war wirklich
etwas was man sich gar nicht vorstellen
kann und der ukraine hat begonnen den
gleichen jahr solche waren in der höhe
von 17 millionen das heißt 20 mal
weniger ist die russin also ich hab so
im ural vorwurf gerechtfertigt ist also
ich hab ich kenne im bericht aus der
welt am sonntag nicht aber wenn die
große koalition das so gehandhabt haben
sollte wäre das nicht in ordnung ist
ganz klar also die us mutter muss man
genau darauf hin prüfen was passiert
eigentlich mit denen sie können mit
maschinen und anlagen mit denen sie
militärisches gerät bauen auf ziviles
gerät bauen das ist diese dual use also
man kann das eine wie das andere man
sich ein auto machen aber indirekt aber
das war so recht helfen wir dann
sozusagen der
güter herzustellen war wenig hat den
artikel gelesen ich schaue mir an
dahinter vor unserer regierungszeit wir
können jetzt nicht hier sagen das war so
wenn es gewesen sein sollte dass es in
der coco so gelaufen ist dann wäre das
mit sicherheit so dass man kritisieren
dürfte so wenig dass auch er tritt in
dem sie das war diese doppelmoral
vorwurf von herrn wenig wir helfen die
ukraine nicht aber das mit russland ist
in ordnung das zeigt dass wir endlich
einheitliche standards für
rüstungsexporte brauchen ist einer der
gründe warum diese koalition sich darauf
verständigt hat dass wir ein gesetz
brauchen das ist dann auch für jedermann
nachprüfbar was solche dinge angeht und
es wird höchste zeit dass wir das auf
den weg bringen wenn ich jetzt richtig
verstanden habe hat der zuständige
minister das ist in diesem fall der für
wirtschaft und klima genau dieses
angekündigt dass das noch in diesem jahr
auf den weg hat auch was andere
angewiesen
deswegen ist das erst mal eine frage die
sich richtet an die praxis einer alten
regierung die sich übrigens in den
rüstungsexport grundsätzen selber dazu
verpflichtet hat nicht in
spannungsgebiete zu liefern und ich war
der überzeugung wenn ich das so sagen da
vielleicht war ich naiv aber ich war der
überzeugung dass nach der
invasion auf der krim genau diese form
der zusammenarbeit ich erinnere mich an
das automatisierte gefechtsfeld
rheinmetall an die hubschrauberträger
dass dies beendet sein sollte weil das
war für mich das mindeste was man nach
der invasion öffnen was ist auch das ist
auch sei ich möchte noch einmal ganz
zurück zu der frage wie nah wir jetzt
tatsächlich vor der möglichkeit eines
krieges stehen anmeldung nehmen sie uns
noch einmal ein bisschen mit in die
ukraine wir wissen die ersten
fluggesellschaften haben ihre flüge
gestrichen wir hören dass die
us-botschaft geheime dokumente verbrennt
festplatten zerstört das erinnert ja so
ein bisschen an afghanistan kann man
sagen oder also die lage ist schon
dramatisch wie gesagt wir sind froh dass
keine panik aus berichtete aber das was
oder worauf wir uns jetzt heute gefasst
sein müssen ist das schlimmste szenario
das bedeutet eben das vielleicht die
hauptstadt schon in den nächsten tagen
bombardiert werden kann mit luftwaffe
und da ist natürlich russland überlegen
und deswegen komme ich wieder zurück zu
dem punkt dass was hier seien das
wahrscheinlichste szenario von dem sie
auch ihren autos sind die szenarien und
jedes von ihnen scheint plausibel zu
sein ob das nur in der ost ukraine oder
im süden eine seeblockade oder auch
jetzt vom form vom norden ihm das auch
die hauptstadt bedroht ist sind keine
zwei kilometer entfernt von der grenze
jetzt haben wir massive drucken auch in
belarus auch da ist die gefahr gestiegen
und zwar massiv das heißt wir wollen
vorbereitet sein auf jedes mögliche
szenario und wir wollen aber auch
um auch die möglichkeiten zu haben was
können wir in gegensätzen diese dieser
über merkte man an der luftwaffe oder
was die schiffe betrifft da sind wir
wirklich eine leichte beute für vier
booten und sie erinnern kann keine
chance gegen die russische armee richtig
haben also unsere entschlossenheit ist
auch glaube ich an ein wichtige punkte
der herr putin aber ich war dort in
lixfeld und dann gesehen wie sich die
menschen vorbereitet haben mit holz
gewähren und und ja ganz ganz alten
gewähren wenn man dann die hoch
technologisierten russische armee sieht
muss man ja sagen da hat die ukraine
daher daher ist auch unsere bitte nach
wie vor an die deutsche politik dass man
über denkt dass man diese
blockadehaltung beiseite schiebt und zur
erkenntnis konnte man kann natürlich
nicht diese
übermacht von von russland jetzt mit
einem schlag etwas
etwas entgegensetzen was wirklich was
wäre aber die situation helfen da wenig
also russland droht damit oder es gibt
szenarien dass er mittwoch ein angriff
kommen was könnte ihre ukraine dann aus
ihrer sicht jetzt helfen also bei dem
besuch von ja wir werden zum beispiel
die über zwei und 2000 panzer die die
russen haben und die sie auch einsetzen
könnten jetzt bei der bodenoffensive
das heißt sollte oder hätte die
ukrainische armee jetzt aus deutschland
diese unterstützung bekommen an anti
panzer raketen dann genau 12.000 stück
ja würden dann vielleicht ausreichen um
auch diese offensive fordern zum stocken
zu bringen fordern sie dass das jetzt
noch passieren sondern auf jeden fall
das ist unsere bitte die die liegt auf
dem tisch diese bitte erneut wir
tagtägliche jetzt auch mit briten waren
im moment haben wir noch keine antwort
bekommen dass er sehr schade weil wir
sehen dieser krieg ist also wie wir
spüren dann auch dieses krieges und wir
spüren den rust von von diesen panzer
die an unsere grenzen rollen aus allen
ecken der russlands und dass das macht
keinen spaß hätten keine antwort auf
diese
verzweifelten der ukraine muss man ja
sagen das land umzingelt von allen
seiten und deutschland antwortet nicht
und sagt nein waffen verteidigung gibt
es nicht ich weiß nicht ob deutschland
nicht antwortet ich habe mit herrn wenig
bei verschiedenen gelegenheiten darüber
gesprochen und er weiß auch was die
antwort an dieser stelle ist insofern
über fehlende antworten übrigens schon
zu der zeit der bundeskanzlerin von frau
merkel kann sich die ukraine glaube ich
nicht beklagen es ist die überzeugung
der bundesregierung der alten wie der
neuen gewesen dass eine wirksame
abschreckung russlands nicht gelingt auf
den militärischen gebiet sondern diese
abschreckung nur gelingt die man
russland vorführt was für einen
politischen und militärischen preis
dieses haben würde aber was ist denn das
herr reicht herr trittin was ist wenn
der angriff ein haben
danach sagen sie diesen preis und ich
glaube das wird wohl kalkuliert an
dieser stelle sein ich bin nach wie vor
der auffassung dass dies der wirksamere
und richtige antwort darauf ist und
nicht der versuch zu machen ein
absolutes militärisches ungleichgewicht
symbolisch ein stück zu verschieben also
ich sehe das anders
symbolisch ist das nicht wie gesagt
12.000 panzer 12.000 anti panzer die
haben sie alle bis mittwoch da also wir
haben seit monaten sie darum gebeten und
erledigt doch gerade die antwort blieb
aus und jetzt haben wir über 1000
flugzeuge also luftwaffe in russlands
das heißt da hätten 1000
luftabwehrraketen vielleicht hätten
gereicht um auch diese gefahr vielleicht
gewisser weise zu bauen wir haben vor
schon vor vielen jahren nachdem russland
die krim besetzt hatte und der
ostukraine der sich eingemischt hatte
heiße diskussionen mit unseren kollegen
im us-senat gehabt republikanern wie
demokraten die geschlossen der meinung
waren man muss den preis für putin
hochtreiben ich formuliert etwas salopp
und eben auch die ukraine militärisch
helfen wir haben dann immer gesagt wir
wollen den konflikt nicht militärische
eskalieren weil am ende des tages hat
russland die dominanz da kann russland
kann immer mehr militärisch zone der
region als die ukraine auch mit noch so
guter unterstützung ich habe diese
position immer mitgetragen aber das bild
hat sich eben letztes jahr komplett
verändert denn putin hat ja einseitig
die situation in der region militärisch
eskaliert und zurzeit vermutlich 130 140
tausend russische soldaten in russland
und belarus an der ukrainischen grenze
das war eben nicht das szenario und das
wollten wir ja genau vermeiden mit
unserem wir wollten ja keinen vorwurf
vorwand liefern dafür russland zu
liefern sie sind deswegen bin ich jetzt
der meinung defensivwaffen für die
ukraine jeden wunsch der ukraine
sorgfältig prüfen also positionen sagen
sie jetzt sind waffen okay nein ich habe
es auch ohne vorher gebracht und ich
möchte den zuständigen bundesminister
zitieren der im mai oder juni letzten
jahres noch als wahlkämpfer am in der
ukraine war und an der frontlinie ein
interview gegeben hat dass ich ganz klar
so verstehe dass er gesagt hat den
wunsch nach defensivwaffen könnte man
den ukrainern ja nie verwehren ich würde
sagen die deutsche bundesregierung
sollte wie wir das in nordiran bei den
pacemaker auch getan haben über ihren
schatten springen es gibt keine
rechtliche es gibt keinen rechtlichen
grund dass deutschland das nicht könnte
wenn das bundeskabinett das beschließen
wollte könnte das bundeskabinett auch
einzelne export wünsche von
rüstungsgütern genehmigen ich fand das
total schade dass scholz in washington
den eindruck erweckt hat das sei in
deutschland gebe es so hohe rechtliche
hürden das ist nicht der fall wir haben
eben gerade kein gesetz im deutschen
bundestag sondern die bundesregierung
hat die flexibilität vor dem hintergrund
ihrer verantwortung gegenüber den
partnern zu entscheiden was sie tut und
ob sie etwas macht ich bin auch dagegen
waffen zu liefern die die russen real
als bedrohung ihres eigenen territoriums
verstehen also leopard panzers kann ich
mir zum beispiel nicht vorstellen aber
wie keine jetzt helfen er hat das ist ja
eine berechtigte frank und integriert
unabhängig davon was man vorher nicht
wollte oder wollte was kann man jetzt
tun damit am mittwoch premier putin
nicht die ukraine angreift bzw dass die
ukraine sich verteidigen also ich würde
zunächst einmal sagen dass die
bundesregierung rasch auf den wunsch es
ist habe ich antworten sollte die alte
volksarmee
panzerhaubitzen liefern wollen an die
ukraine das geht möglicherweise recht
schnell und die sind auch vielleicht
nicht so kompliziert dass also die
panzerhaubitzen sofort an die front
nicht an die front sondern in der
ukraine an die stellen positionieren wo
man einen möglichen angriff mit diesen
waffen abwehren kann das sind keine
waffen mit dem man das territorium
russlands bedroht sondern das sind
waffen mit dem man im zweifel verhindern
kann dass die russischen streitkräfte
wie ein messer durch die butter auf
kaschieren sondern dass sie schon wissen
dass sie ein hohes militärisches risiko
gehen der lernsoftware für mich nur ein
teil der antwort sie sind ich sage mal
frühere diplomat weil sie jetzt
politiker sind sie kennen sich aus in
dem geschäft kann schon sagen am
mittwoch oder am dienstag bei wladimir
putin wenn nichts passiert dann schicke
ich panzerhaubitzen oder lasst die
panzerhaubitzen durch aus estland
beeindruckt das war dem putin ein das
sind 9 haubitzen die sind über 50 jahre
alt die stammen aus den beständen der
ddr die ändern nichts und das ist ein
punkt wo man einfach sich über eines
ganz klar sein muss ich habe das am
anfang gesagt
was hier als szenario droht also eine
große in version ist nicht im nationalen
interesse der russischen föderation
es ist das ende der beziehung zu europa
das muss man sagen das muss stolz sagen
joe biden hat bedeutet das das ende der
beziehung dass wir unsere botschaften
hatte aber vielleicht will der
immobilien auch ja dieses ende ja wir
wissen dass nicht er hat ja große angst
vor europa mit vielleicht ist bedeutet
dass wir die wirtschaftsbeziehungen auf
das absolute minimum maß zurückfahren
das betätigungsverbot erlassen werden
dass es schwieriger werden wird für
russische banken sich zu refinanzieren
es wird ende für eine vip karten
preisgeben wirtschaftlich wie wir das in
der vergangenheit noch nie gemacht aber
das sage ich jetzt gibt ein herr rolf
einmahl wir hören das immer aber es ist
ja auch wahr es ist ja auch war der
punkt ist doch der wenn wir haben keine
chance und das ganz klar zu sagen den
ukrainischen streitkräfte so viele
waffen zu liefern dass wir an der stelle
die strategische
kalkulation im kreml ändern können folgt
vollkommen ausgeschlossen sie glauben
doch nicht im ernst dass wladimir putin
angst vor neuen transfer haubitzen aus
der ddr habe aber er wird wo sind habe
es geht nicht um haube ist dann ist es
nur ein 1 1 1 1 1 test ja ein lackmus
die deutsche politik ja ich gehe ja
nicht um diese 19 oder neue metropole
geschäfte der außenminister hat ja als
annalena baerbock in kiew und klar
gesagt hat nein es wird aus deutschland
keine legalen waffen also keine
tödlichen das haben dann nehmen wir das
hat er nicht gesagt okay dass korea bok
hatte ist gesagt herr kollege hat dann
gesagt sehr diplomatisch sehen hat
gesagt das stimmt aber ist es nicht auch
hier sowieso gar nicht durch sagt ich
habe auch noch gar nicht gesagt dass wir
cool immer gesagt sie an der
pressekonferenz kann man ja nachher er
hat gesagt wenn wir waffen brauchen
wissen wir auch wo wir sie her bekommen
können und ich glaube das ist wichtig zu
wissen wir haben in deutschland nicht
vor 2014 als bundeskanzlerin merkel als
die cdu-regierten damit 2014 im
angesicht einer einseitigen eskalation
von putin das war ja die krim und der
don baesweiler einseitige eskalation da
hat die damals cdu geführte
bundesregierung gesagt wir machen keine
waffen sondern wir machen sanktionen und
wir setzen russland unter druck und wir
haben jetzt eine situation wo die
strategischen kalkulation im kreml nicht
durch ein paar opitz aber heirat werden
sondern nur durch die meisten hatten in
den vergangenen jahren nicht mehr für
rapid ich erinnere mich ich war reporter
in der ukraine und immer da habe ich
gehört dass es jetzt dann die
windlichter ronzheimer was
sie sagen es hat nicht geklappt das
ist doch nicht weiß ist weil die
situation immer geworden der nachricht
von der schlinge russland so den hals
der ukraine aber schon die krim dass der
ukraine gut aus und sie wissen genau
dass diese dauernden spekulationen
gegeben hat mario pohl wird angenommen
dass sie das neue russische projekt alte
schlusspartie onken wurde wieder
ausgegraben katharina die zweite das
odessa eingenommen wird es gab diese
ganzen szenarien die sind alle nicht
gekommen und wir wissen nicht ob da
nicht diese sanktions kalkulation im
kreml dem ganzen zu grunde gelegt wie
ist ihr eindruck hat dass irgendetwas
gebracht der eindruck den die ukraine
heute haben ist dass wir von den
deutschen auch im stich gelassen werden
weil
man kann viele ausreden finden sollte
aber aber es geht darum dass die ukraine
jetzt nicht das gefühl haben dass sie
sich auf die deutschen in dieser
schwierigen lage verlassen aber darum
gehen könnte schon sagen dass wir mehr
tun als die allermeisten anderen auf der
welt waren es geht nicht darum
situationen
ist die wahrheit das letzte aber nicht
interessiert es interessiert ihn nicht
dass deutschland der größte investor in
der ukrainer ist es interessiert ihn
auch nie das stimmt das ist eine
deutsche bundeskanzlerin war die nicht
meiner partei angehört die dazu
beigetragen hat dass weiterhin gas aus
russland durch die ukraine durch
geleitet worden ist sondern sie
versuchen an der frage von 16 oder neun
museumsreifen panzerhaubitzen die
deutsche zuverlässigkeit in frage zu
stellen und ich finde das hat dann auch
mal so erreicht man dann auch so eine
grenze wo man sagen muss ja da haben wir
einen dissenz ich drücke das jetzt mal
setzt er diplomatisch
ich widerspreche weil sie sind herr
hennig ich widerspreche ihrer behauptung
dass die alte bundesregierung oder die
jetzige bundesregierung die ukraine im
stich gelassen hat mich nicht gefragt
wie wichtig ist auch dem wieder hat er
ihn auch das sagen sie selber was sie
selber vergangenen donnerstag hier mit
der bundesregierung sie waren bei der
entwicklungsministerin sie waren beim
wirtschaftsminister sie haben mit den
fraktionen gesprochen hat dann
offensichtlich erwarten sie von etwas
und sie haben es auch als zusagen
bekommen ich war dabei wir haben gar
nichts bekommen also herr trittin 8 uhr
ihre frage 1,8 milliarden euro dass sie
jetzt in den vordergrund stellen das was
die ukraine in den letzten acht jahren
bekommen haben wir sind dankbar dafür
wir schätzen dass aber alleine das dass
die dass deutschland jetzt noch 72
vorangetrieben hat hat dazu geführt dass
das wir innerhalb eines jahres zwei
milliarden us dollar an gebühren
verloren und das wird auch weiterhin
gehen und nur wenn ihn drei wegen aus
dem 2 und wenn in drei jahren den
sitzungen liegen kommt wie es aussieht
oder sogar früher dann heißt das dass
wir jedes jahr nur noch 34 jahren woher
sollen hierbei ist ein super sich vor
dem mandat soll das ist eigentlich vom
markt fernhalten deswegen weiter das
serien das ist natur und ja ich hätte
ihnen auch zurück nicht widersprechen
herzlich willkommen zurück bei die
richtigen fragen an einem dramatischen
wochenende an dem uns die frage umtreibt
kommt es zum krieg in europa und wir
diskutieren hier in der runde unter
anderem mit dem ukrainischen botschafter
an remake darüber was deutschland jetzt
tun kann um das noch zu verhindern wir
haben gerade über nord stream zwei
diskutiert eine ewig lange diskussion
bild kann ich sagen hat schon seit ganz
ganz vielen jahren gefordert dass diese
pipeline nie in betrieb genommen werden
dafür nicht wie nehmen sie jetzt die
diskussion hier der politik war was nord
stream angeht also wir sind froh
zumindest dass diese debatte heute
anders verläuft wie noch vor einigen
jahren und dass man diese geopolitische
dimension dieses projekt das ähnlich in
deutschland erkannt hat das ist schon
ein guter punkt aber gleichzeitig was
wir sehen wie sehen das dass die politik
jetzt eigentlich dieses thema auf die
technische ebene weiter geschoben hatte
die bundesnetzagentur sollte eben über
die zertifizierung und inbetriebnahme
entscheiden und wir glauben und dass die
politik doch immer noch in der pflicht
ist auch gerade weil wir vor einem
möglichen neuen großen krieg stehen auch
da das machtwort zusammen sollte also
sollte olaf scholz der bundeskanzler
wladimir putin am dienstag sagen nord
stream 2 ist sofort vorbei wenn es zur
invasion kommen sollte weil noch zwei
hat zumindest bislang nicht in den mund
genommen hat gesagt alle optionen lägen
noch auf jeden streit und nicht nur herr
putin persönlich aber auch in die
öffentlichkeit und auch das tun aber
sofort auf eis legen das ist das was wir
erwarten er tritt ihn noch zwei sofort
auf eis legen die grünen haben immer
gegen nord stream gekämpft in den
vergangenen wien gegen nord stream
beispiel wette gegen die europäischen
klimaschutzziele und es war etwas wo am
ende wieder in der tat die gefahr sehen
einer destabilisierung der ukrainer das
ist der kern dieses und deswegen ist
gesagt worden in der jetzigen situation
es liegt alles auf dem tisch da liegt
auch noch warum nord stream in den
ersten bundeskanzler fragen wer zahlt
aber sogar aber ich will nur auf
einweisen es ist nicht nur nord stream 2
was auf dem tisch liegt das muss klar
gemacht werden dass es ganz andere
bereiche zum beispiel mit zugang zum
banken die frage wie gehen wir sie haben
eh würde wir haben eben darüber
gesprochen was so genannte dual use
güter angeht das sind der zum teil auch
sachen die für die exploration der
gasfelder von zentraler bedeutung ist
technologie- und ähnliche dinge all
dieses liegt auf dem tisch und ich bin
fest überzeugt dass olaf scholz dem
bundeskanzler
dass der bundeskanzler dem herrn putin
sehr deutlich sagen wird was die dinge
da sind erlaubt was ich nicht verstanden
habe die ganzen jahre wo diese krise
eben schon so groß geworden ist wieso
ist es möglich das russische oligarchen
kinder weiter im westen studieren warum
ist es möglich dass sie in saint tropez
urlaub machen können in london villen
bauen all diejenigen die eng an putin
dran sind und dieses land umzingelt ein
anderes und wir schauen einfach zu auch
sergej lawrow auf der außenminister und
seine familie hat immer wieder new york
genossen und sozusagen die westlichen
vorzüge warum tut man da nicht sie ist
interessant dass die berlinische wenn
also wir haben wissen dass hier in
berlin manche russische oligarchen
riesigen real estate also
immobilienbesitz haben das ist in meinen
augen aller der unbefriedigten zustände
die wir übernommen haben als wir die
bundesregierung jetzt eingetreten sind
dass man da noch nichts vorbereitet hat
die ausrede der alten regierung war
immer na ja wir konnten da nichts machen
man muss sich an konkreten nachweis
haben dass person ist
quasi strafbar gemacht hat nur dann kann
man sie mit einer sanktion belegen und
natürlich machen die oligarchen ein
hütchenspiel und sage ja gut das ist
meine frau mein sohn also wäre dann der
immobilieneigentümer es ist immer jemand
anderes kennen wir doch mal köln
neukölln das ist ja ich sag ja das ist
eigentlich das problem zentrum new york
dann lassen bleiben was christian thunig
klar ich glaube ich glaube tatsächlich
wir müssen ein bisschen politischer an
diesen ganzen sanktions gedanken
rangehen wir haben bisher ein sehr
juristisches verständnis von sanktionen
es muss alles immer ganz konkret was
kann auch die einzeln oder sowas kann
man zu naja man kann dann versuchen
hinzugehen zu sagen also wenn wir nicht
sicher sind wo das geld herkommt mit dem
immobilien ex finanziert worden ist dann
werden wir immobilie ex requirieren das
gibt es kleinkriminalität das gibt es in
anderen europäischen städten es gibt da
noch nachholbedarf aber da brauchen wir
haben auch eine financial intelligence
unit so heißt die also so eine art ist
dem italienischen modell gerade der di
finanza nachdem vor also richtig
knallharte phase sollte sollte nachschub
augenblick und nochmal beiden zu bleiben
am dienstag mit putin sagen also nord
stream auf dem tisch liegen weitere
wirtschaftliche sanktionen auf dem tisch
banken verkehr aber auch sagen russische
oligarchen die villen in europa in
berlin haben diese werden wir ich nenne
es mal konfiszieren ich finde das ist
eines der szenarien mit denen man
operieren muss einfach um klar zu machen
dass wir das für eine wirklich
existenzielle situation halten in der
die europäische friedensordnung wir
reden über die ukraine ich verstehe auch
die leidenschaft botschafter mit der sie
hier argumentieren denn das ist das
betrifft sie und 04 trifft freunde und
bekannte verstehe das total aber das ist
ja noch größer als jupiter die ganze
europäische friedensordnung werden in
europa grenzen mit gewalt verschoben
kommt der krieg nach europa zurück das
ist ja diese frage die wir hier haben
und diese riesig und assistiert haben
wenn man ihnen die villen weglassen wenn
man und verbietet was was muss man ja in
die private banking konten einfrieren
immobilien wegnehmen das sind die dinge
die ein äusserst hat es hat ja nach der
besetzung der krim personen sanktionen
gegen einzelne gegner lächerlich das
waren ja ganz während esther ihrem
ansatz kanzlerin einige das erinnern was
hier einige kenne ich die im europarat
für die russische delegation unterwegs
sind und die große probleme haben dann
den notwendigen ausnahmegenehmigung zu
bekommen weil sie natürlich an diesen
europarats werden sicher anlegen sollten
wir noch irgendwie hin ja aber wenn sie
dann in berlin waren mussten sie schon
zügig zum flughafen und nicht noch durch
den kudamm also ich werde ihnen einmal
zeigen wir reden über sanktionen ich
will ihnen mal zeigen was der russische
botschafter in schweden zur frage gesagt
hat was mögliche sanktionen des westens
russland angeht nämlich er hat den
besonderen satz gesagt dass den russen
das ganze eigentlich scheißegal sein und
man solle aufhören mit diesen debatten
entschuldigen sie meine ausdrucksweise
aber wir scheißen auf ihre ganzen
sanktionen das ist er für mich ein
ansporn dass wir da offensichtlich auf
dem richtigen weg sind ja also ich
bestände nur nüchtern fest dass putin
viel geld viel geld was den bürgerinnen
und bürgern des landes gehört den und
die gagen durch monopolstellung in den
in den in das portemonnaie gesteckt hat
für sich selbst vorsichtig ausdrücken
und dass dieser liga somit nicht daran
denken dass geld in russland zu
investieren weil sie nehmen wir an die
zukunft dieses land auch nicht wieder
luft nach oben sondern sie investieren
das war anders und wenn der sie da
anpacken und ich bin 100 prozent der
meinung wenn wir dort zurzeit noch zu
zahnlos sind in der europäischen union
dann müssen wir das ändern dann glauben
seine wirkung habe und was nord stream 2
angeht da werfe dem deutschen
bundeskanzler schon vor offensichtlich
hat er ja mit beiden verabredet dass
trotzdem zwei nicht kommt wenn es zu
diesem einsatz kommen denn beiden hat ja
von wir gesprochen
ja wenn es zum einen was kommt dann
werden wir dafür sorgen dass wir bezogen
auf das vorangegangene gespräch mit dem
deutschen bundeskanzler und dass der
deutsche bundeskanzler dann bedrückt
sich möglicherweise auf seinen alten
parteifreund nicht den mut zu sagen
austin 2 und erhält er nur sagen müssen
dann wäre alles klar gewesen und ich
würde mir schon wünschen dass in den
nächsten in den nächsten stunden die
kraft findet das auch deutlich
auszusprechen ist gesendet wir deutschen
wirklich auch im bowling in den augen
anderer unsolidarisch es gibt experten
er hat die sagen oder die schließen sich
dem an was der botschafter aus schweden
dort gesagt hat er die sagen wladimir
putin plant das ganze was jetzt passiert
seit jahren seit jahrzehnten er ist
jetzt in dem gewissen alter er will in
die geschichtsbücher und er wolle
sozusagen sein sowjetreich das sowjet
imperium was er damals als
geheimdienstmann hat untergehen sehen
wieder zurückerobern hermeling ist das
eine theorie von der sie angst haben
das ist ein ganz klarer plan denn wir
schon auch seit jahren sehen und diese
erkenntnisse war bis zuletzt hier nicht
so spürbar das was was studien anstrebt
ist also die ukrainische staatlichkeit
einfach zu zerstören und und seinen
einflusszonen wieder herzustellen so wie
das in der zarten zeit und dann in der
sowjet seite fall war deswegen glauben
wir schon dass man das was borussia will
er die villa die nato zurück drängen
oder die ukraine besetzt das nato und
alle dieser spreche über garantien das
ist nur ein 1 1 schönherr vorwand der
natürlich auch hier bei der
öffentlichkeit leider ankommt dass man
gut verstehen ist dass man quasi das
dass seine sorgen wirklich anzunehmen
sind das alles ist natürlich völliger
quatsch denn ihm geht es darum dass er
seinen plan weiterhin frei wollte ob mit
wasser waffengewalt oder mit anderen
massnahmen
cyberattacken
informationskampagnen aber wie sähe das
aus herne können wir uns vorstellen
tatsächlich dieser ich muss nochmal
darauf zurückkommen dieses
horrorszenario das anderes passiert
tatsächlich wie würde wladimir putin
dann die ukraine unter kontrolle halten
all das was ich dort erlebe ist eine
zivilgesellschaft die dann
möglicherweise in einen partisanenkrieg
gehen würde ich weiß nicht oder glauben
sie dass wladimir putin irland unter
kontrolle halten könnte wir sind bereit
für unsere land für die heimat zu
kämpfen weil wir viel zu oft in der
geschichte und zwar nicht nur in den
letzten jahrzehnten sondern auch hinten
runter zurück unserer staatlichkeit
verlieren mussten deswegen stellt für
uns alles auf dem spiel gleichzeitig
haben wir auch in der bild zeitung
gelesen diese szenarien dass man
internierungslager schon heute
vorbereitet dass man auch ein
machtwechsel vorbereitet und das heißt
dass man schon strategisch denkt dass
man nicht nur natürlich die truppen und
jetzt schickte das werde natürlich auch
kein spaziergang für ihn weil wie sie
sagen die ukraine natürlich da sind und
sie werden kämpfen für für das land das
ist das stellt nicht in frage er tritt
ihn halten sie das für möglich dass
russland tatsächlich die ukraine
besetzen kann und langfristig unter
kontrolle halten kann ich glaube das
wäre ein sehr blutige tun aber es ist
nicht ausgeschlossen dass er diesen
irrtum beginn
gibt andere szenarien die sagen es
kommen zur partiellen besetzungen oder
der implementierung einer regierung die
sich sozusagen in von den glatten da ist
das ist alles offen noch mal egal welche
form der militärischen intervention der
stadt findet es wird eine harte antwort
aus europa gemeinsam mit den usa an
dieser stelle geben und das ist dass der
hinter kablow dem jetzt scholz in nach
moskau
ich will ihnen einmal zeigen was us
präsident joe biden gesagt hat zu der
frage was uns hier auf der ganzen welt
drohen könnte nämlich das ist ein
weltkrieg wenn amerikaner und russen
beginn aufeinander zu schießen diese
konkrete warnung und die dort
ausgesprochen wird herr lambsdorff haben
sie auch sorge naja als digital ist aus
dem zusammenhang gerissen nicht also da
ging es darum dass die frage gestellt
wurde werden amerikanische soldaten in
die ukraine verlegt angesichts der
russischen bedrohung der joe biden ganz
klar gesagt ja keines kann nato mitglied
und wenn wir da amerikanische soldaten
in schickten dann könnte das zu einem
weltkrieg führen also insofern dass die
tat so wie es da ist aus dem
zusammenhang gerissen ich glaube das was
jürgen trittin ihre hat er gesagt er ist
genau das was ich ganz am anfang gesagt
haben in russland geht drei großen
irrtümer wenn es meint mit der inversion
da zurecht zu kommen das eine ist eben
wirklich ein langer blutiger
widerstand aus der ukraine heraus die
ihre staatlichkeit bewahren will und
vergessen wir nicht so dominant putin im
russischen politischen system auch so 20
24 sind präsidentschaftswahlen wenn es
verlustreiche kämpfe gibt und die
komitees der soldatenmütter gründen sich
wieder von kopf bis wladiwostok und in
jeder stadt gibt es serie die da
ankommen und es gibt unmut und ärger in
der bevölkerung in politik
das ist eine das ist eine der
kalkulation von denen ich dem kreml nur
raten würde sie zu machen wir hören ja
die entschlossenheit der ukraine das
zweite ist der dax mit dem westen ist
drittes die totale abhängigkeit
russlands von ina das kann doch alles
nicht im russischen interesse ist wenn
das passieren sollte er hat haben sie
sorge dass putin das ist ja das was auch
immer aus der ukraine zu hören ist dass
das nur der anfang ist vitali klitschko
hat sich heute in der bild am sonntag
geäußert und hat gesagt dass dann
möglicherweise als nächstes die
baltischen staaten dran sein und man
immer weiter vorrücken würde halten sie
das für möglich dass putin nicht nur
richtung ukraine spielt sondern sagt
okay dann will ich wirklich das gesamte
reich zurück haben ich habe bereits
darauf hingewiesen dass belarus immer
stärker auch unter der kontrolle
russlands kommt auch militärisch mit dem
hinweis auf die veränderung veränderung
der russischen verfassung ich habe auch
den 1 dass russische truppen nicht nur
an der
litauer an der ukrainischen grenze
stehen sondern eben auch richtung
polnischen litauischen grenze
stationiert werden möglicherweise auch
mit mittelfristige und langfristige
dauerhafte stationierung und wir wissen
dass russland immer wieder
vorträgt es müsste eine landverbindung
zum region kaliningrad geben aber ich
wollte hier werden diese trotha fürs
auto gebaut ich sage wehret den anfängen
wir müssen wir müssen vermeiden dass sie
zum einmal in der ukraine kommt und wenn
es zum einmarsch in der ukraine kommt
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass es der
anfang vom ende von der herrschaft von
vladimir putin ist und dazu ist eine
starke widerstandsfähige ukraine genauso
wichtig wie eine klare politische und
wirtschaftliche sagt das ist mit den
baltischen staaten herr trittin ich habe
auch mal aus der ukraine gehört ja wer
sagt uns denn dass putin sozusagen im
innersten sagt mensch also die ehemalige
ddr die gehört auch zu meinem
einflussbereich
ja sie können vieles rein interpretieren
und ganz viel spekulieren ich glaube
dass die hürde ein nato staaten
anzugreifen weil der satz von beiden
denen sie eben eingespielt habe auch
umgekehrt gilt wenn russische soldaten
angefangen auf amerikanische oder
britische deutsche in litauen zu
schießen dann ist dann tatsächlich eine
eskalation an dieser stelle da die nicht
im interesse russlands sein kann ich
finde wir sollten auch mal versuchen die
dimensionen klar zu machen was was putin
macht ist ein stück
brutalster
militärischer fast terroristischer
herrschaft sicherung aber er tut das auf
der basis eines staates der über
atomwaffen verfügt aber ein
bruttosozialprodukt hat wie spanien das
durchschnittseinkommen des russischen
bürgers ist heute niedriger als das
eines chinesischen bürgers das ist die
situation auf der putin
vermeintlich auf der weltbühne spielt
und deswegen ist diese frage der
botschafter der gesagt hat eure
sanktionen interessieren mich nicht da
bin ich ganz bei hanhart da hat jemand
gesagt hat ja gar nicht wehgetan und
hielt sich dabei
am himmel nicht was macht das mit ihnen
wenn sie hören wenn nato-staaten die
sind ja geschützt sie haben das versucht
damals 2008 in die nato zu kommen und
jetzt heißt es ja gut können wir leider
nicht ja das ist genau und der punkten
härte ding gerade anspricht weil man in
der nato ist ist man geschützt und und
deswegen oder gerade deswegen ist die
gefahr eines möglichen einmarsches im
baltikum
aus unserer sicht sehr unwahrscheinlich
weil man natürlich dann mit den
amerikanern mit den deutschen mit den
dritten zu tun haben wird und deswegen
wollen auch wer ukraine teil dieser
familie werden auch deswegen da wollen
auch wir beitreten diesem
verteidigungsbündnis und das ist ein
bündnis um die mitglieder zu verteidigen
und wir wollen das auch einen eigenen
beitrag leisten ist nicht so dass wir
sie haben flüchten wollen sie haben
gezeigt wir sind bereit zu sterben wenn
es sein müsste für die eigene heimat und
wir sind bereit auch einen beitrag so
leicht haben wir sorge haben sie sorge
dass die amerikaner oder auch die
europäer am ende die ukraine opfern und
sagen na gut ukraine ist nicht teil der
nato an russland nicht weitergeht dann
also mein präsident hat gesagt wenn
deutschland jetzt in einer lage wie wir
uns befinden würde dann hätten wir auch
den deutschen geholfen das hat er vor
wenigen tagen gesagt und wir glauben
dass es die einen die einzige option
eigentlich die auf dem tisch bleibt dass
die ukraine teil dieser familie wird von
der nato und nicht wie heute in diesem
grauen zone weiterhin existieren müsste
weil das ist auch diese existenz dieses
so stand alleine wäre eine einladung für
putin immer wieder schwachstellen zu
suchen und auch herumschlagen rtt
ukraine in die nato gibt es dafür eine
chance oder ist es nicht vielleicht
sogar genau umgekehrt was man hört dass
man marco scholz und andere in richtung
putin eine art moratorium geben wollen
um zu sagen nein die werden eh nie teil
der nato ich weiß nicht was nie ist wir
werden festhalten an dem prinzip des
freien bündnis wahl in europa gibt freie
bündnis wahl in europa heißt aber nicht
dass alle alles aufnehmen müssen und ich
sehe angesichts der jetzigen
konfliktlage die nächsten jahre manche
sagen auch jahrzehnte
keine möglichkeit dass die kleine die
voraussetzung erfüllt die man bräuchte
um der nato beizutreten da sage ich
nicht alleine sondern das ist glaube ich
in der nato sehr gefestigt aber warum
ist das so wenn ein land darum geht ein
land was zum beispiel nicht über eine
geschlossene territoriale integrität
aber ich habe es selbst mit deutschland
wurde in die nato aufgenommen
obwohl die das land gespalten die
bundesrepublik fest ja aber ich meine
rede der das war die entscheidung die
damals auch eine mutige entscheidung war
nicht abzuwarten bis deutschland
wiedervereinigt werden kann soll ich bin
ja nur herunter einmal mich gefragt und
ich habe versucht aus bestem wissen und
gewissen aus der kenntnis der
überzeugenden meinung der mitglieder der
nato der parlamentarischen versammlung
der nato der ich auch angehöre ihn zu
berichten und danach ist die neigung ein
land mit offenen territorialkonflikte
aufzunehmen in der nachbar 2008 bauten
sie dort auch schon ich wollte also
deutschland nehmen dass ich sage ich sag
ja
das ist der stand und ich glaube auch
nicht dass sich da nächster zeit etwas
ändern wird herr lambsdorff aus
diplomatischer sicht was wird olaf
scholz wir kommen da auch als ende der
sendung was wird olaf scholz putin in
richtung nato sagen können denn bleiben
wie putin sagt seit jahren und jetzt
ganz verstärkt denn die der westen muss
ausschließen dass die ukraine teil der
nato wird wenn sie jetzt alle sagen wird
eh nicht passieren weil ist nato staaten
gibt die dagegen sind was spricht
dagegen dann bleibe ich mit putin dass
in irgendeiner form zu garantieren auch
vor dem hintergrund dass man die ukraine
da provozieren könnte aber dann wäre
doch der konflikt vorbei oder versteh
ich das falsch nein ich glaube das ist
nicht der punkt der punkt ist endlich
ein folgender wenn olaf scholz nach den
gesprächen die joe biden heute und immer
neue makro mit putin führen wir müssen
alle sehen dass das der gesamte westen
ist er hier an dieselbe botschaft
rüberbringt da muss die botschaft ganz
klar sein wenn hier eine invasion kommt
es geht einmal um die ukraine und das
duo keine widerstand leisten wir haben
wir gerade gehört aber es geht immer um
viel mehr es geht um viel mehr es geht
um die position russlands in der 21
jahrhundert der welt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts werde ich
ein vasallenstaat chinas werde mich wie
die totale abhängigkeit chinas
dort sei was die nachfrage war so
kompliziert werden 2008 ein gipfel da
wollten die amerikaner dass die ukraine
und georgien der nato beitreten
frankreich und deutschland mit der
bundeskanzlerin merkel haben sich damals
dagegen aus aber was ist wenn wladimir
putin sagt und da unterschreibe ich hier
ukraine in die nato oder sagst neid-elf
stolz wird überhaupt nichts alleine
unterschreiben sondern wir werden alles
was wir tun gemeinsam in der nähe so
dass zwischen den europäern und mit den
amerikanern abstimmen die die politik
der offenen tür bleibt in der nato
erhalten punkt aber das wird in jedem
fall eine einzelfall entscheidung sein
so wie es 2008 waren atom-moratorium was
jetzt so rum gehört also ich glaube
nicht dass das also schon mal kann ich
kann der deutsche bundeskanzler das
alleine entscheiden das soll unsere
jemals ein paar bruch der verträge wir
haben ihn wir haben in den verträgen die
russland die so wird und somit
unterschrieben hat und die russland
bekräftigt hat bei jeweilige überlegung
feiern der charta von paris und im
übrigen auch beim opa bruder pesta
maranow mit der ukraine das die länder
souverän sind dass sie ihre grenzen
geschützten und dass jeder die
möglichkeit hat seine bündnis frei zu
wählen wir können wir können nicht ohne
selbst vertragsbrüchig zu werden eine
solche zusage gegenüber russland gehen
und dir vorstellen und das russischen
präsidenten der könne eine solche zusage
bekommen dies absurd und das macht nicht
eben skeptisch weil ich sage wenn er
doch eigentlich wissen muss dass er das
vom besten sich erwarten warum betreibt
das dann doch soweit auf die spitze und
deswegen stelle schusswunde er hat ich
bitte sie darum nicht festzulegen haben
wir in der nächsten woche krieg ich
glaube es nicht
ich halte ich für ausgeschlossen
deswegen müssen wir alles tun um es zu
verhindern
alles tun das zu verhindern animagic zum
abschluss wir müssen bereits seit und
hoffen auf die hilfe aus deutschland
immer noch die hilfe aus deutschland der
meinung die wir euch hoffen dass kein
fauler kompromiss was die nato betrifft
über die köpfe der ukraine hinweg
und das auch keine geheimen absprachen
geben sollte weil darum geht es keine
wird versprechen dass es keine nato
beitritt der ukraine geben wird aber wir
können ja nichts ausschließen dass man
um dann kriegst du verhindern da war es
mal wie möglich hinter den
verschlossenen türen tut das wäre also
war der sprache keine geheimabsprachen
das wird und das ist das risiko ist da
und wir hoffen dass das nicht geschieht
und wir appellieren an unsere freunde in
deutschland und in den usa auch das
nicht zuzulassen sonst aber die
historischen figuren mit denen sie
gerade spielen sind wirklich bei unseren
mittel und osteuropäischen freundin
absolut beängstigend also das wird nicht
kommen ein deutscher bundeskanzler wird
nicht mit einem russischen präsidenten
über die köpfe von ländern in mittel und
osteuropa irgendwelche abkommen wir
hoffen da schließen wir hoffen dass er
lambsdorff als kann ich ihnen
versprechen gewählt wird weiter
berichten über die ukraine über die
situation dort ich selbst bin ab morgen
in kirf und werde für sie von vor ort
berichten das war es mit die richtigen
fragen herzlichen dank
[Musik]